the topic of counting or combinatorics
is an important one in a number of dis
at different disciplines and and notably
in computer science so the origins of
the combinatorics and counting are a
little bit disreputable they come out of
historically out of people studying
gambling and trying to calculate odds
and the fraction of times that various
events occur to know what kind of bets
to make on them so a typical kind of
question would be if you know how poker
works there are various classifications
of five-card hands in poker you might
ask what fraction of all possible
five-card poker hands translate into
being a pair of jacks and is basically
this fraction of total poker hands which
fit into the category a pair of jacks is
the probability of a pair of jacks so
counting and gambling is one fundamental
place where it really comes up and
historically that's where a lot of
combinatorics begins related to that is
counting in games when you're trying to
write for example a computer programming
a computer program to play chess or
checkers or so on one of the aspects of
it is getting a sense of how much
searching you have to do in order to
look ahead to find good moves and you
wind up counting from a given chess
position how many possible further
positions can you get to in a given
number of moves a puzzle kind of
question in solving the Rubik's Cube toy
is how many different positions are
there and how many different positions
can you get to from a given position
concretely in computer science it comes
up in algorithms it's often the case
that a central question is how many
operations does it take to do a
manipulation on a data structure inta
updated from one to another for example
how many comparisons does it take to
sort n numerical items and there's a
typically the countless n log n proof as
someone as a number of operations that
are both achievable and a lower bound
one that we've seen when we looked at
fast exponentiation is in question like
if you're trying to compute the the nth
power of a number d how many
multiplications does it take it's
roughly log n by using the iterated
squaring method and we want to be able
to count that number of multiplications
that a particular program uses to
compute D to the N and the largest of
the smallest number of multiplications
you can get away with and a place where
again we're we're counting and
combinatory becomes critical is in for
security and the issue of of
cryptography if you're going to have
security from passwords there needs to
be too large a space of passwords for an
adversary to search through exhaustively
and check them likewise for the if
you're doing encryption with some kind
of secret key that enable you to read
messages you want to be sure that the
space of possible keys is also way too
large to search exhaustively to see what
keys work so let's talk briefly now
about the very basic counting methods
and two rules for accounting things the
most rudimentary of them but in fact we
get some mileage out of them so the
first rule is called the sum rule and
it's completely straightforward and
obvious which is that if I have two sets
a and B that do not overlap then the
number of elements in a union B is
simply the number of elements in a plus
the number of elements in B and there's
no issue proving that it's self-evident
but let's do an example suppose the
class has 43 women and 54 men how many
how many people are in it 43 plus 54
equals 97 this is implicitly assuming
that there's no one whose sex is
ambiguous and that there's no third sex
and so that men and women are disjoint
the total number of students is the sum
of the number of men and women another
one is there are 26 lowercase Roman
letters in 26 uppercase Roman letters
and
ten digits and so there are 26 plus 26
plus 10 equals 62 characters in that
repertoire of of symbols the second rule
is called product rule and it's just
about as obvious
suppose I have four boys and three girls
how many boy-girl couples can I can I
assemble out of four boys and three
girls and the answer is there are four
ways to choose a boy followed by and for
each of them there are three ways to
choose a girl so there's four times
three or twelve possible boy-girl
couples in this setting more generally
if I have a set a of size M and a set B
of size n then a cross B remember that's
the set of ordered pairs where the first
element is from a and the second element
is from B the size of a cross B is the
vertical barge member of a mean size is
equal to M times n so let's just do an
example that illustrates it suppose that
a is the set of four elements little a B
C and D and B is the set of three
numbers one two and three then I can
list a cross B in a nice orderly way as
a four by three matrix but this is
really meant to be just the list of
elements but I'm organizing this way so
the pattern is more apparent and for
each boy a or each element little a I
can pair it with each of the three
elements in B and for the second element
little be in a I can pair it with this
three digits in a and C I can pair with
three and D I can pair with three and
that's where the four times three comes
from and more generally the M times n
comes from
a useful immediate application of this
is how many binary strings are there how
many strings of zeros and ones are there
of length four well the straight the
length four binary strings it can be
explained as as the product of B times B
times B times B and we're not writing
parentheses here it's B times B a cross
B so I'm thinking of a quadruple like
this as being a pair consists element is
triple and a triple is a pair whose
first element is a pair and given that
it doesn't really matter how you break
it up we just typically write it as B
cross B cross B and even abbreviate that
as B to the fourth where B is 0-1
and the rule the product rule says that
the size of this is the size of B times
ties the size of B times the size of B
times the size of B or two to the fourth
so in general if I look at strings of
length n whose elements are LR from an
alphabet of size M the total number of
such strings is M to the N